a birthday bash relationship whiplash
and a G&G clash
now let's rehash it all on sweet let our
secrets hey there river babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and welcome
to your after-show for episode 315
chapter 50 American Dreams now we've got
a lot to discuss today and I'm going to
be sharing a new bug-head interview with
cool Sprouse and Lily Reinhart plus a
quick but sweet moment with Vanessa
Morgan so let's just jump right into the
most important plot points that happened
this week in the blue and gold breakdown
first up looks like it's time to keep up
with the Joneses because they're moving
in next door that's right
turns out Gladys was the anonymous buyer
who snagged the Cooper house what else I
was Cooper doing in my house
thanks to Betty who heard it from
Veronica Jughead finally found out that
his mom is the one who's taking over the
candy drug trade in Riverdale and jug is
pissed this is criminal Miss selfish but
he just didn't have the heart to tell
his father the shocking truth at his
50th birthday bash here's 250 Dan and a
50 more meanwhile Archie has seen better
days I was doing pretty good mr. Lodge
until the homeless kid stabbed me in my
house he discovered that Hiram passed
out 12 of those killed the red paladin
cards so Jughead put his game master
skills to the test and they came up with
a plan to end this weird storyline once
and for all
so continues our nerdiest mystery yet
the ten remaining G&G nerds
I mean gamers who had the card each had
three minutes to try and take down
Archie in a boxing match because sure it
was brutal it was bloody and someone
even bit him
but in the end Archie defeated them all
and while Archie was in the middle of
the fight for his life Sheryl and Tony
were having a secret rendezvous at
labahn OE which leads us right into
seven seconds in heaven now as you know
things between Shoni have been strained
for a few episodes now we don't have to
go anywhere ever cheryl has been
distancing herself more and more from
the pretty poisons and she had a flurry
of a red-hot rage when she saw Tony
having an innocent moment of fun with
Veronica and the gang
[Music]
after casing the speakeasy Cheryl
crawled back into her cat burgler ways
and was about to rob the place but in an
intense twist Shoney's relationship
tension turned into full-on sexual
tension and it was hot and nice like I
was shocked that the CW was able to air
all of that I was in the mood to gamble
now despite the fiery montage
it seems that Shoney's flames might be
burning out maybe it was too soon
maybe you moving out as exactly what
needs to happen this all just feels
really sad and weird and confusing and
what color me shocked but another
breakup news with Gladys firmly back in
town and taking over the Cooper house
Allison FP shared a truly heartbreaking
scene and I'm sad to say it but it looks
like phallus is ending before we even
got to see a smooch do you love me
doesn't matter now and as for Veronica
and Reggie well they also had a tale of
woe in this week tired of being her
hunky sidekick
I want to matter Reggie asked to be a
full-on business partner but Veronica
basically said a polite hell no we even
be dating if not for the speakeasy
probably not looks like veggie is
officially off the la bonne nuit menu
how could you have done something so
reckless but what about bug head well
they're good this week they were a solid
crime solving duo with Archie's best
interests at heart but now it seems like
they have a new mission save jelly bean
protect my dad and run my mom out of
town do you want to help take a look at
what cole sprouse and lily Reinhart had
to tell me about Betty and jugs solid
season three journey I think it's
interesting I think the teen dramas
oftentimes lean into the whole rocky
relationship thing and I think this show
does something kind of inverse to that
which is the couples for the majority of
the seasons
stay strong which i think is interesting
I mean they definitely have their faults
and Betty and Jughead play into each
other's sort of wild emotional and
investigative passions quite a bit but I
think
I think they're doing well what has been
your favorite Betty Jughead scene of
season 3 every Betty Jughead season 3 I
think the G&G stuff was a lot of fun I'm
interested to see where it goes because
sort of where we're heading is going to
be a really interesting path but I
really did like to change II stuff Eddie
it's all making sense all of this is
becoming clearer : and we're saying that
I loved the scene when Cole's like deep
in the gene G wormhole I'm Betty's like
you do that yeah I'll go solve some
mystery all this awesome mystery is it
but you're okay you keep playing I'm
gonna go figure this out as long as she
like knew where he was he wasn't getting
into trouble she's like you just stay
here I'm gonna go figure this out oh
it's the game it makes people crazy what
has been your favorite Betty and Jughead
scene to film in season 3 I feel like
all the episodes are starting to blur
together me now you know to be honest
Betty and Jughead have not spent that
much time together this season
none of the core 4 has really cuz
they've all been on such different paths
like drastically different with kind of
only infrequently crossing each other
which has been kind of sad because we
all loved working together but these
characters have their own stuff going on
mm-hmm
I can't pinpoint a specific let's say it
hasn't happened yet oh yeah yeah what
has been your favorite bug had seen so
far this season shout out your thoughts
to me in the comments below as we switch
over into this episode's rendition up
hisses and kitchen first up hisses to
all of the breakups in this episode
Dallas made me teary-eyed veggie made me
depressed and Shoni just made me really
really confused
come again moving in with someone is a
big step and not something that you
should hold over your girlfriend's head
I think it's really mature of Toni to
want to have a life filled with friends
and fun and a balanced relationship what
is that exactly
moving on despite the fact that he was
tolerable this week and I liked his red
sweater I'm still sending hisses to
Hyrum Oh Archie I'm so sorry I tried to
have 12 guys kill you here's a boxing
gin we could no hisses to Gladys for a
pudding Jughead in a
position and forcing him to keep secrets
from his father
is there a problem job but I'm also
sending her kisses because I think she's
keeping things really interesting and
I'm really digging her whole vibe
switching fully over to kisses that one
of course is going to Fred Andrews and
his super-sweet bromance moment with FP
at their birthday party
we love you Fred me too
[Music]
kisses to all the sweet father-and-son
scenes between Jughead and FP and kisses
to the fact that hopefully we're done
with this whole red paladin nonsense for
good time will tell
kisses to finally getting some B and V
time at their sweet sleepover and kisses
to seen the fun side of Veronica and
Toni's friendship in fact this was
something that Vanessa Morgan was hoping
to see more of take a look at what she
told me on the set of episode 13 I love
all my scenes with Cammy like I just
think that there's some kind of like
it's like Tony and Veronica scenes are
awesome you know they have a good
chemistry they're good dynamic duo I'd
like to see more of them together we've
got a deal and we're gonna end it there
now thank you all so much for tuning in
to this Sweetwater after-show for
episode 315 and I'll see you next time
for a super special preview of Riverdale
second musical episode that's right
episode 316 chapter 51 big fun will be
Heather's The Musical and I've got so
many behind-the-scenes secrets for you
all any questions I thought not okay bye
but first please give this video a like
hit subscribe so you never miss an
episode of Sweetwater
then head on down to the comments to
tell me your hisses and kisses for the
week which riverdale breakup hurt you
the most
do you really think Jughead will be able
to betray his mom and which bug-head
scene has been your favorite this year
tell me tell me and I'll see you soon
river babes fine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]